I believe Trump demonstrated you could
go around the party you could decapitate
a party temporarily
and that's plausible apparently I
wouldn't have said so but it is
apparently plausible well he didn't go
around it he went through it he took it
over right yeah I would say he went
around it and you know stepped in front
of it and became its head
um which you know
the thing is Bernie was in a position to
do the same thing to do the same thing
same thing but he he held back a bit
Trump went all out Sanders held back a
bit well you know I don't know either
man but I would say
the difference is that uh Trump is
the kind of player who
understands everything to be a
legitimate move in the game
and Sanders is constrained by
his morals some some moral code that
limits what moves he can make which
allowed
Hillary Clinton who I believe is much
more trump-like we'll play any move
as a legitimate move in the game it
allowed her to drive him into
irrelevance and frankly to paint people
like you and me
as Bernie Bros remember that yeah yeah
crazy that just came out of nowhere it
was just like wait
suddenly this is about
being a dude
I thought this was about like working
people getting the shaft and somebody
wants to fix that they had to paint a
working class movement as sexist I mean
and racist and so bad and the funny
thing is and it's you know it's reuse
it's used every cycle practically I mean
uh apparently during the 2018 sorry 2008
um Hillary Clinton campaign
pushed this Narrative of the Obama boys
online
yeah that's that's gross yeah yeah well
so but okay this this actually then is
right back in uh in your area of
expertise because it looks to me
like there's a set of epithets
that are so terrifying to people they're
socially terrifying things that if you
are accused of them cause most people to
buckle because they do not know how to
field the accusation right the thing
that uh captured people's attention
about my confrontation at Evergreen was
it the students that I was a racist
these are students I'd never met by the
way
these students that I'd never met said I
was a racist and I said no I'm not and
most people couldn't imagine how a white
Professor was going to survive just
simply saying no that's not true right
so the point is there was a question
about can you figure out how to stare
down a bad accusation right and that bad
accusation can be conspiracy theorist
it can be anti-vaxxer it can be racist
it can be transphobe it can be Bernie
bro it can be apparently Obama boy right
um so I guess the point is at some point
does this it's a single trick there's an
epithet it sounds like the end of your
social life if it gets appended to you
and so everybody is bending over
backwards to make sure it doesn't get
directed at them
right if
they keep doing this and then it turns
out that a a certain number of us figure
out how to stare it down and that b the
People Who Stare it down turn out to be
uh
safer or uh insulate themselves from
some kind of authoritarian oppression
then at some point people are going to
realize that they're epithets they don't
mean anything right they've robbed these
I mean some of these things
we need to be able to accuse racists of
racism right how dare you burn that one
up accusing people who aren't guilty of
it of being racist you've just let all
the racists off the hook right how could
you right you want to abuse Nazi you
want to let Nazis off the hook because
that's what you're doing right so I
don't know what do you think are the are
the epithets eventually going to lose
their power when one after another turns
out to be political garbage
I think they are losing their power but
it might just be you know I worry that
it's just
you know by Network my right uh
re recognizes that it's but
there's still huge bubbles of the
population that
you know the the you know one of the
bigger ones the Democratic party bubble
a lot of anybody that's still a part of
that party they still believe that stuff
that you know they take the bait every
time otherwise they wouldn't be in the
Democratic party cult anymore I mean I
understand you're registered but we're
not really in you know identify as
Democrats that's the question when I
hear
that
[Music]
um
my concern over mRNA vaccines
is going to make me an Untouchable from
the point of view of
New York Times reading NPR listening
Democrats
my thing my feeling is
that is is that's a zero cost right with
the exception of some very old people
who have read the New York Times who
read it back when it was a newspaper who
listened to NPR back when it was public
broadcasting before these things were
pure propaganda Outlets all right
there's some people you know some very
old folks who can't seem to get over the
loss of those properties and they still
believe in them but
in terms of
one's interactions in life generally
apart from their older relatives
I don't
I don't need to make sense to New York
Times readers those people are
inherently confused in fact if I'm
running my life around trying to make
sense to a New York Times reader then
I'm going to end up like Bernie Sanders
where suddenly I'm useless
yeah right so so I guess the point is
the I think a lot of the
threat
is
in people's minds that the the cost of
actually confronting these epithets is
small because frankly a lot more people
are aware that these are nonsense than
you are led to believe yeah yeah and it
and it I mean honestly it almost gives
you uh
more credibility now because it shows
that you are perceived as a threat to
you know the establishment
and I mean I'll say you know when I was
canceled
you know it did seem like it was being
um
you know shamed and attacked by more
people than it actually was I mean
privately many people many people were
you know
knew it was and they
uh sympathized with me privately
um
so that was I mean it's a shame more
people couldn't say it publicly but at
least that did at least you know show
them show me that
this is just you know appearance on the
surface you know most people or at least
a lot of people can see through this and
I guess every time someone
just responds rationally calmly like you
did and just asking you know
basic questions you know then they
go on to expose themselves
as you know often the ones who are
bigoted
um
it's funny like
I mean that that's the the way hatred is
expressed now
is is by accusing the hated of being
hateful
and when yeah like I said when you
respond as you did just like calmly and
clearly it really exposes uh the scam
yeah you know
the more I think about it
when I was confronted by students again
people I had never met
leveling an accusation that I personally
knew had no merit
the thing that
well a the first thing is
they confronted me with my class people
I did know
and I think it took me months to realize
this but I think they were expecting my
class to defect on video right because
of course
students accusing a white professor of
racism
you know in 2017
surely you're gonna find people saying
yeah and you know you're gonna have lots
of disgruntled students or whatever and
of course not a single one of my
students defected because they knew me
and they knew it was garbage too and all
of the students that I had had in years
prior didn't affect either for the same
reason
but it was also true
that in class we were talking about
racism and where it comes from and what
it has to do with Evolution and what
needs to be true in order for it never
to rear its ugly head again you know
um
and I also had my own
history I could look back at my own
history and I could check you know do
they have a point no they don't have a
point I I can prove they don't have a
point
so what I'm getting at is
I was in a very unusual position when
they leveled that accusation at me which
was that I knew no matter how many
rounds we went
there was nothing for them to find they
weren't going to find a shred of
evidence that this was true and I had a
whole lot of evidence that they knew
nothing about from my earlier history
that I could have brought to bear if
need be to establish that their
accusation was nonsense but
who has that that's rare yeah and what
they're doing by effectively
creating hyper awareness of race at
every moment is preventing people from
living a life that could generate that
evidence
I was lucky to generate lots of
interracial interactions you know
in a context where everybody knew that
the objective was to make race
less important right everybody every
good person understood that race had
been too important and that it needed to
become unimportant and that although
you can debate where we are relative to
a colorblind society that that's where
we should be headed right
so in that world
I had lots of experiences that I could
point to
somebody who grew up 20 years later
would have had
experiences in a world where race was
always
charged
right
and so the point is part of the
Diabolical aspect of the strategy here
is that it prevents people from
um
living a life that would tell them that
what they were being accused of was
nonsense so I think lots of people have
self-doubt
yeah that I'm a racist than maybe I am
that's what they think
yeah no really I mean it's
yeah especially people who are
you know open-minded which is I think a
good important type of person to have
and you'll be like oh like you said oh
did I do something wrong and uh and
honestly like I you know ask myself that
when I was being all these accusations
were being hurled against me
um and it happened so fast fast Brett
like I was given no time to even defend
myself like
um and I mean I I had drafted an apology
the Sanders campaign leaked it to a
report I said I said this is for you to
say yes I'm I'm happy to resign
because you know I don't want to work
with I I already explained why I had my
like reservations about working for them
when they were really going to give me
creative control but anyway
um
they it got so the apology which I said
was still just a draft gets leaked to
the Press but anyway after
um that was all within like an hour of
being pressured to resign and within an
hour I had no time
I looked back at the videos
I was like that ain't bad that really
ain't bad uh and so it is kind of
imagining anyway that just
um well but big another big what makes
it so diabolic
as you were saying
in addition to what you were saying is
that it is so like you can't prove a
negative right or it's very difficult to
yep
it's very difficult to
um which is part of what they count on
and they also count on the game theory
which is
they point this super weapon at you and
the idea is we'll pull the trigger
unless you demonstrate your
subordination to us in which case we'll
move on to somebody else
and so
staring it down is terrifying not
staring it down causes it to spread it
becomes effectively contagious because
each person capitulates and drives them
onto the next person and at some level
you just gotta stand up and say no
that's nonsense
foreign
[Music]